west africa is facing a resurgence of
ebola
the first since the end of a 2016
outbreak which killed more than 11 000
people
now back then the epidemic began in
guinea and now
that same country has recorded seven new
confirmed cases
including three deaths now could this be
the start
of a fresh epidemic or has guinea
learned some lessons from before
ebola is back in guinea in the first
identified case one person died last
week in the southeast
the same region where the virus first
surfaced in 2013.
officials say some people who took part
in the funeral of the new case
soon reported symptoms of the virus
tested samples confirmed that it was
ebola
and news of its resurgence is already
worrying ghanaians
i was in panic i couldn't even control
myself
when i learned that ebola had returned
to guinea
because of what the virus did in 2013
and 2014
in guinea sierra leone and liberia
we are africans we are poor
and if diseases like ebola or the
coronavirus appear in africa
it's only god who will save us
i'm really surprised given the current
situation in guinea we
gideons are struggling with the covet 19
pandemic
and now with ebola it will be a real
disaster
the memories of the last outbreak are
all too real
the virus hit guinea hard and caused
similar devastation in neighboring
countries
this time the world health organization
says it's on full alert
and is seeking to make vaccine doses
available
as quickly as possible guinea's
government says its diagnosis time has
been reduced to less than two weeks
compared to three and a half months in
2014.
with covert 19 already causing great
hardship in guinea
it's a race against time now to contain
ebola
and prevent even greater calamity
you